yes
morning
i now remember
that is
um
are you sorry
yes
trump just called for military
is
is
there it is
you don't have to apologize
can you do that
just to make sure
that's right
no no because he made a video
oh
yes
foreign
no i'm just sure
okay
peace
is
yell out
right
hey thank you
right
[Music]
shut down
okay
all right
yes
is
yes
problems
yes
just in case
hey
is
is
so much
this
okay
oh
if
the dna
good to see you too okay it is so great
to welcome back
uh our administrator of the
environmental protection agency
michael regan uh he's here to talk more
about the bipartisan infrastructure
framework
which includes the largest investments
in the nation's clean water
infrastructure including funds needed to
eliminate and replace
a hundred percent of lead water pipes
and service lines
across the country pipes and treatment
plants are aging and polluted drinking
water is endangering public health
studies show that for kids higher
exposure to lead
negatively affects academic performance
and can lead to cardiovascular
disease later in life the investments in
water infrastructure in the framework
are unprecedented and also include
funding to modernize
wastewater systems across the country
including in rural areas and on
tribal lands he also just came from the
president's meeting on wildfire
preparedness
with western governors as well and after
that we'll do a full briefing
as always i'll be the bad cop when we're
ready to take questions and it needs to
go thank you so much
thank you good afternoon i just came
from the president's meeting
on wildfires with western governors the
increasing
intensity of wildfires in heat out west
is a major public health challenge
president biden is bringing leadership
and resources the resources of the
federal government to help those on the
front lines
in our western states i briefed the
president his team
on what epa is doing to help keep people
safe the epa has developed tools to help
provide the public with reliable
information to inform
and protect people when wildfire smoke
is causing dangerous air quality issues
in their communities as part of the
administration's broader efforts to
improve wildfire
preparedness epa is deploying additional
new sensors in heavy smoke areas
to assess air quality we will be adding
the fire and smoke app
to the air now mobile app next month so
that firefighters families and people
throughout the communities in the west
can take action to reduce their exposure
you can learn more about this resource
tracking smoke and air quality
at air now.gov backslash fires
and visit ready.gov backslash wildfires
to learn about actions you can take
now to prepare for wildfires and stay
safe
you know this is one powerful example of
why we need to do more
to rebuild our infrastructure that would
that can withstand the impacts
of climate because as wildfires rage out
west
floods are consuming communities
elsewhere
the extreme weather events americans are
experiencing year-round underscore the
need
to make bold investments needed to
tackle the climate crisis
the bipartisan infrastructure framework
would make the largest
investment in american history nearly 50
billion dollars in the resilience of the
physical
and natural systems breathing air and
drinking clean water are at the heart
of president biden's buildback better
agenda because he believes
no family no child should be still
drinking water from lead pipes
water infrastructure is a huge part of
the president's american jobs plan
and it's carried through in the
bipartisan infrastructure framework
and for very good reason clean and
healthy drinking water
and safe and effective storm water and
wastewater infrastructure
is necessary for every thriving
community
yet as you see here on the screen there
are still an estimated six
to ten million lead service lines that
need to be replaced all across the
country
in the few months since i've started
this job i've had the chance to hear
directly from communities
and visit water infrastructure sites and
programs all around the country
in st louis missouri where there are
still an estimated 28 000
lead service lines i visited a drinking
water plant that is more than 100 years
old
the director there told me that we need
to invest in our water infrastructure
before it's too late in illinois where
there are four hundred thousand less
service lines
just in the chicagoland area i heard
from people who are struggling to
address
the urgent need for lead pipe
replacement
we know that low-income people and
communities of color
are disproportionately at risk when it
comes to lead
contaminated drinking water and last
week in baltimore
i had the privilege of meeting with the
young folks who were joined
who joined a job training program that
are now successfully
working in water infrastructure jobs
getting clean and healthy drinking water
to people
isn't a political issue it isn't a
partisan issue it's an american issue
access to clean safe drinking water is
fundamental to protecting
all people regardless of regardless of
zip code or how much money they have in
their pockets
and that's why the bipartisan
infrastructure framework
makes a transformational 55 billion
dollar investment
in our nation's water infrastructure
including the funds
needed to replace our nation's lead
pipes
this will be the largest investment in
clean drinking water
and wastewater infrastructure in
american history
by upgrading and repairing our aging
infrastructure it will ensure people
have reliable
access to safe and clean drinking water
that they deserve replacing less service
lines will bring
long overdue progress to overburden
communities
that have been disproportionately
impacted by exposure to lead in their
drinking water
and by putting dollars into our
communities it will create
good-paying union jobs and strengthen
the future
water workforce of our nation the
bipartisan infrastructure framework
is a critical first step to implement
president biden's vision
to build back better enhance our climate
resilience
and ensure clean air and clean water
we know that there's more work to be
done which is why the president will
continue
championing his full american jobs plan
president biden's leadership on
responding to wildfires in the west
building our nation's resilience to
climate change and prioritizing water
infrastructure
is already bolstering the work for epa
and i'm grateful to the president i'm
grateful to congress and the american
people for their ongoing
bipartisanship support on these very
important issues
all right ahead thanks
sir in the meeting with the governors on
water rights
was there any discussion of water
allocation decisions in the western
states with any of the governors today
no no discussions there
basically we discussed that we're
experiencing a very tough wildfire
year upcoming year we talked about
staying very closely
coordinated and the president talked
about providing additional resources
uh for resilient infrastructure and and
water management and forest management
what was your discussion about rolling
blackouts really blackouts to prevent
uh wildfires was there talk about that
no any other concerns that the
governor's brought up that you know that
we
need to know about just that we need to
work closely federal and state
uh uh leveraging resources and again
staying in close coordination throughout
this fire season wild fire season
um can you talk about given you're
talking about extreme weather
events like what's happening with the
heat wave in the pacific northwest
can you talk about how that factors into
your enforcement strategy at epa
and cracking down on polluters well what
i can say is that we're really
laser focused on these climate change
impacts and so therefore
we really are deploying our air quality
monitoring systems
to help folks understand the
implications of wildfire pollution
uh we really are ramping up enforcement
in this in
in this epa we believe that enforcement
is a tool
in our toolbox that need to be deployed
so that we can keep everyone on the
right track
talk about also i know that epa is
hiring up to a thousand new staff
can you give an update on how that's
going and
what areas you're looking to hire in
we're looking to hire
and really we had a lot of people lead
the agency during the previous
administration
what we want to do is continue to build
on our scientific integrity
our ability to capture and push data out
and and really develop the sound
expertise amongst
all of our professional classes to
inform how epa does its job
and accomplish its mission thank you
thank you for being my question um
do you support pursuing additional funds
um
beyond the bipartisan plan in the
reconciliation plan
for drinking water in particular you
know i think the president has made it
clear
that he's got ambitious goals laid out
in the american jobs plan
uh this water in this um this
infrastructure framework
is what we're seeing as a first critical
step so he's got a number of tools in
his toolbox
we're happy that he's gonna deploy those
tools not only for water infrastructure
but for climate as well
as a follow-up question about what's
going on in florida um the epa has said
that there are particles that could be
toxic to people's long-term health
um related to the collapse of the
building in florida
is the epa making any recommendations or
suggestions
to try to protect people that are living
in the area and of course the first
responders who are searching
the rubble we're actively engaged with
all the elected officials on the ground
our regional offices are deploying air
monitoring systems and the latest
information
to be sure that we keep the public safe
are you confident
that the people that are searching the
rubble that they're getting the
protection that they need
so that they don't end up like the first
responders of 9 11 who of course
suffered all sorts of long-term health
issues i'm confident that our agency is
partnering with the sister agencies to
provide the
latest and best information so that
those on the ground
can govern themselves in a very safe way
thanks john administrator the last
several days here in washington right
across the street from this building
have been protesters who've been holding
signs saying things such as
buying you coward fight for us what's
your response to that criticism and if
you could assess the claim that they're
making that the president on that issue
is a coward
you know what i can say is that this uh
is a historic
investment this is the largest
investment in american history
both on water infrastructure but we also
see some strong movement on climate
in this infrastructure bill as well when
we look at the supply chain for electric
vehicles
when we look at charging stations that
will be deployed all across this country
what i would say is a first critical
step
but the president is holding tight to
his vision uh and the president
is looking again at all of the suite of
options that he has
from a toolbox perspective to pursue the
goals that he's laid out
thank you you mentioned that the epa in
dc is in touch
actively involved with uh or actively
engaged with officials in florida
do you agree with that energy secretary
granholm that it's possible to serve
side
condos collapse maybe a result of
climate change
you know i don't know if we have enough
information at this point you know what
i'll say is uh
epa both our headquarters and our
regional offices
are coordinating with the state of
florida and folks in that region to
really understand what's happening on
the ground
and be sure that we're deploying
adequate resources to keep
uh that um those actions
safe for those folks uh thanks john uh
there are millions of people across this
country who don't are not on
the water system they rely on well water
so to those millions of people
every time you test their wells they're
coming up with fecal coliforms
arsenic antibiotics antibiotics and
other heavy metals
what does this do to address those
millions of rural and suburban people
who are not
on a water supply line but rely on well
water
you know epa we have a lot of tools
existing to focus on water quality and
water quality protection
what i would say again when we look at
these infrastructure
bills they're doing a really good job
not only to help
with less service pipelines and water
infrastructure
you know only but when you look at the
american rescue plan you look at the
president's very ambitious
budget for epa what we're doing is we're
bolstering our ability
to collect the data and information we
need to keep the public safe
and where we need to lean in on our
enforcement well i understand that but
in
response to what steve was saying there
are those who are rural and
and suburban uh residents who believe
that the cowardice in the administration
comes by not addressing
a very real issue about poisoning well
water are you addressing that
i think we're looking at a range of
options options to look at water
pollution uh
we fast i think we've got a number of um
budget requests in uh that we hope the
the congress approves for epa to really
bolster its actions there
i think that there are a number of tools
in this tool pop
toolbox that the president is deploying
to get at water quality
quarter quality protection for all
citizens so there is money allocated for
it
for to address that water well issue
there is money in this
there's war there's money in the
president's budget request for epa
to do a better job of looking at water
quality protection for all americans
okay we're going to do lynn and josh and
then we've got to let the administrator
go back to
fixing our pipes thank you for taking my
question noting that you did mention
chicago
what is the timetable or the timetable
for a timetable
of appointing a much-needed regional
administrator
for regional five democratic michigan
and illinois members of congress
have been pushing competing contenders
as i'm sure you know deb sharp
and michael raglin for the job what's up
we're on an expedited time line i uh
just spoke to
top candidates this morning and
yesterday morning and so we're pushing
those recommendations
over asap so when you say top candidates
are they micah ragland and dem short or
is it someone else
just so i know specificity
yes i spent time with two top candidates
this morning and yesterday
and we're going to push those forward
asap and how fast does asap
well that depends on how we work with
the white house to get it done
so i don't have a specific timeline in
terms of how we
navigate the personnel process but we're
pushing as fast as we can
listen we recognize that we need our
regional administrators
in place if we're going to be successful
to expedite
and execute on the president's very
ambitious agenda
on climate on water quality
environmental justice and the like so
this is a top priority for us
all right josh uh i want to go to the
lead service lines
uh could you break down the timeline for
when you think all of these would be
replaced and then secondly on the issue
of cost
how are you looking at cost we're told
that it would cost on average twenty
seven
thousand dollars to replace a lead
service line in chicago
but the administration seems to be
budgeting it around four thousand to six
thousand dollars you know our estimates
show that
with the the ask that the president has
in this infrastructure plan that we can
replace 100
of the lead pipes obviously when you
look at timelines
uh we that really is city by city
instance by instance
we are ready to engage with our state
partners the good news is
epa has water infrastructure programs in
place we have the infrastructure
to push these resources through to
partner with our state and local
officials
to get this done on an expedited
timeline will it be done overnight
absolutely not will it be done as
quickly as possible that's what we're
pledging to do so
what's the range between overnight and
as quickly as possible
well we haven't gotten that far yet in
terms of putting an
actual timeline on the quickest city we
could do
and the one that would take the longest
term but you can come back
thank you so much administrator
appreciate your time thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
okay
um just a few more items for all of you
at the top um as you all know and noted
um and
in your questions uh the president
convened cabinet officials governors
from western states and private sector
partners this morning to discuss
how we can all work together to
strengthen prevention preparedness and
response efforts
in the meeting the president asked
participants what additional resources
they needed
and what immediate actions can be taken
to protect communities improve emergency
preparedness
and address the growing wildfire threat
both by preventing them from happening
and ensuring the federal government's
response is as quick and effective as
possible
and to do that we also announced a
series of actions today to address the
growing and severe threat of wildfires
protect communities from devastation and
save lives
which were outlined this morning we can
certainly talk more about as you may
have also seen
in a few minutes the president will sign
the sergeant ketchum rural
veterans mental health act which will
create three new mental health centers
for veterans
battling severe mental health issues
including post-traumatic stress disorder
it's estimated that at least one in five
veterans returned from combat
with a significant need for mental
health support yet 85
percent of veterans coming home to rural
communities are in areas with a shortage
of professional support
as the president has repeatedly
reaffirmed we have a sacred obligation
to care for those who serve and this
bipartisan bill will help our rural
veterans get the support they need
later this afternoon the president will
also sign three additional bills
one to protect our climate from methane
one to protect consumers from predatory
lenders and one to protect workers from
employment discrimination each of these
bills are common sense protections that
pass
with bipartisan support bipartisanship
alive and well in washington watch out
um
also today the white house will host a
virtual
eviction prevention summit to support
and facilitate coordination among local
public officials
court officials legal services legal
service organizations local bar
associations
community-based organizations emergency
rental assistance
administrators and local philanthropies
from cities across the country
to work on developing local eviction
prevention action plans
this summit is just one of a number of
steps we are taking
uh that we announced last week i should
say to keep people in their homes by
protecting renters
and helping state and local governments
prevent evictions
uh also in our in our ongoing news about
getting vaccines out to the world
um we are shipping 2.5 million doses of
johnson and johnson vaccines to colombia
as a part of our continued effort to end
the virus everywhere
finally sorry i have two more things and
then we'll go to get to questions today
uh vice president kamala harris led the
u.s delegation to the generation
equality forum
in paris and provided live virtual
opening remarks
she restated the united states
commitment to gender equality
and she made the case about how gender
equality is tied to democracy following
her remarks
we announced several robust deliverables
in three areas gender-based violence
economic justice and sexual and
reproductive and health
rights as one final note and as a point
of privilege
uh today is the last day of pride month
and i am honored to host a pre-recorded
virtual convening on transgender
equality
uh later this evening at this convening
young transgender and gender non-binary
leaders from across the country will
share stories
about the impact the state-level
anti-transgender legislation
has had on their well-being their
experiences of multiple
intersecting forms of discrimination and
best practices for advancing acceptance
and the program will feature a range of
officials uh
from the federal government as well as
openly transgender athletes
leaders and elected officials with that
josh go ahead
thanks jen two subject areas russian
president vladimir putin says that a u.s
reconnaissance aircraft
was operating in sync with the british
destroyer last week in the black sea
was the u.s coordinating with the
british ship and was this as putin
claims of provocation
i don't have anything to detail or
confirm from you here from the podium
i'd certainly point you to the
department of defense on any specifics
as the president noted when we attended
the summit when he participated in the
summit just a few weeks ago
uh our objection our objective i should
say is certainly to move forward a
on a more predictable and stable
relationship with russia we
he announced a number of forward-looking
actions in that regard
and that certainly is guiding our
strategy and then secondly south dakota
governor
christie gnome said she'll use the
donation from a republican donor to fund
the deployment
of up to 50 south dakota national guard
troops
to the u.s border with mexico does the
white house have
any concern about this as a proper use
of and the funding mechanism for
national guard troops
i would certainly have to check with our
team on that uh josh i'm happy to do
that after the briefing go ahead stephen
walk us through what the president will
be doing tomorrow in surfside florida
we'll
actually visit the building site
uh well i know first there's a lot of
questions about this and as details
become
finalized and available we will make
them all available to you
so let me outline for you what we have
at this point which is pretty consistent
with what i outlined just yesterday just
one moment
so while the president first lady who is
joining him on this trip
are in florida tomorrow they will be
thanking heroic first responders search
and rescue teams and everyone who's been
working entirely around the clock
they will also meet with families who
have been forced to endure this terrible
tragedy in terms of the logistics and
the schedule of the day
we're still finalizing those details of
course we hope to have
them all nailed down before the end of
the day given this trip is tomorrow
but unfortunately i don't have many
additional specifics at this point
he'll visit the building or just not
able to announce it yet
but we're still working out the final
components of the trip tomorrow and
as i would note and the president
repeated this to me multiple times
yesterday
uh every component of this is going to
be needs to be coordinated with
officials on the ground
there is still an ongoing search and
rescue effort on the ground and we want
to ensure we're not doing anything to
pull away from those resources
and secondly afghanistan are you now
days away from completing the
withdrawal i'm seeing a number of
reports about this
uh well i would say that we remain on
the timeline that the president
announced just a few weeks ago which is
to get our troops out of afghanistan
well having a remaining diplomatic
presence on the ground by september
in terms of the specifics of the of the
operational components of that i'd
certainly point you to the department of
defense but
nothing has changed on our timeline or
objective the president planning
an event around the pull out
there's not a planned event at this
point that i'm aware of
go ahead go ahead if i can follow up
very quickly on afghanistan
i know the timeline remains the same is
the u.s can the u.s commit
that all interpreters drivers others who
help the u.s
force during its commitment in
afghanistan will be out by the time of
its departure
well i would say peter that uh what our
focus is on now is
expediting that processing as you know
we announced just
last friday that we were taking steps to
evaluate options for moving individuals
to
another location so that they could
complete their processing individuals
who are already
in the pipeline in terms of the numbers
or what that looks like
those operational components are still
being worked through so the potential is
that there may still be some
in that case no we're working to do that
which is what i conveyed on friday we're
working to do that on the timeline in
advance of the withdrawal of u.s troops
i would also note though that we will
still have a diplomatic presence on the
ground that is our continued commitment
and that will continue after september
of austin miller he's the general there
the commander in afghanistan for the
united states who said yesterday to
reporters
civil war is certainly a path that can
be visualized if it continues on the
trajectory it's on
he said that should be a concern for
the world what is the president what
does this white house say about that
concern from its top commander
on the ground down afghanistan given
their already seeing taliban violence
increase in large swaths of that country
well i would say
peter that when the president met with
the leaders of afghanistan just last
friday
he reiterated our commitment to working
with them and continuing to support them
whether it's security assistance
humanitarian
assistance or other ways that we can
play a constructive role
even as the president is uh continuing
to and we're continuing to
operationalize on the withdrawal of our
troops i'd also note that
when the president made the announcement
about our decision
it was in part based on a timeline that
was committed to by the prior
administration of may 1st
and if we kept our troops in afghanistan
after may 1st
they would be shot at and that was a
decision that as a commander-in-chief
he had to make there have been
assessments out there made by our
intelligence community and others about
the conditions on the ground
we are going to continue to work with
leaders in afghanistan as the president
reaffirmed last friday but it's not
changing our plans or our timeline for
removing our troops this last question
is making headlines across the country
right now
we just heard from the pennsylvania
supreme court that bill cosby's
conviction for sexual assault has been
overturned they can no longer
pursue those same charges against him in
the future right now the president
obviously has
long commitment to violence the violence
against women the fact that he helped
write the white house's reaction to that
first of all
well first as you noted those reports
just came out shortly before i came out
here
i don't have a direct response from the
white house to
that announcement i will say which you
touched on and i'll just use the
opportunity to reiterate that the
president
has long been an advocate for uh
fighting against violence against women
for ensuring that we are
uh raising uh the voices and the stories
of people who have been survivors of
sexual assault that's something he has
done throughout his career and will
continue to do
uh but oh i don't have a specific
comment on that announcement today if we
do have one after the briefing i'll make
that available to all of you go ahead
thank you
what does the white house think about
congresswoman ilhan omar saying that she
does not regret comparing
israel to hamas and the taliban
well any attempt to draw an equivalency
between the united states and our close
ally
israel with a terror group like hamas or
the taliban is false and
unacceptable uh representative omar has
said that was not her intent of her
comments
uh but uh those certainly are not
comments that we've made from here
and on another subject he's mentioned at
the last briefing that you think
republicans wanted to defund the police
because they did not support the
american rescue plan
which republican ever said that they did
not like the american rescue plan
because they wanted to defund the police
well first let me just note that
the president ran and won the most votes
of any candidate in history on a
platform of boosting funding for law
enforcement
after republicans spent decades trying
to cut the cops program there's record
of that
that doesn't require anyone having new
comments
and then also stood in the way of
crucial funding needed to prevent the
laying off of police officers as crimes
increased that's a simple statement of
fact
i understand what you're saying there
however
there are lots of examples of democrats
explicitly saying
they want to defund the police we've got
congresswoman cory bush congresswoman
iama presley alexandria cassio cortez
gilhan omar
are there any examples of republican
members of congress
saying they want to defund the police i
think most people would argue that
actions are more important than words
wouldn't you say
well to that point to your point there
at the time of the vote on the
american rescue plan you had the
republican leader in the senate mitch
mcconnell he said
he just didn't like it because he
thought it was a classic example of big
government democratic overreach in the
name of velvet relief
and then kevin mccarthy said he thought
democrats were using coronavirus as an
excuse
to justify funding pet projects well
where is the here
again i think actions speak louder than
words peter so
if you oppose funding for the cops
program something that was
dramatically cut by the prior
administration and many republicans
supported
and then you vote against a bill that
has funding for the cops program
we can let other people evaluate what
that means it doesn't require them to
speak to it or to shout it out their
actions speak for themselves
go ahead two questions uh the first one
on infrastructure
in reference to the bipartisan support
here we just heard from house speaker
nancy pelosi she's doubling down on this
idea that
she's going to hold on to one bill until
she has the other but we've also heard
from
leader mcconnell and he says that
president biden's clarification is just
a hollow gesture
unless democrats like pelosi agree to
changing their approach
so does the strategy by the house
speaker risk
bipartisan support for this deal well i
would say that what
leaders in the party have asked the
president to do is to go out there
and make the case for how this bill how
this piece of legislation will help the
american people
he just did that in wisconsin yesterday
he just had his epa administrator come
out and do that for all of you
and we think the american people are
most focused on what this is going to do
for them and less on the process
it's up to leaders in congress to move
this forward the president looks forward
to signing both pieces of legislation
into law but if republicans are
expressing concern saying they may not
vote
for this bipartisan package unless
these two are not linked in some sort of
way is this putting that deal in
jeopardy
again i will leave it to you and to
leaders to evaluate and i will leave it
to leaders in congress to determine the
sequencing and the process moving
forward the president looks forward to
signing each piece of legislation into
law
i just asked one quick question on
police reform sources are telling us
that
they have now had a major roadblock in
negotiations i'm curious if the
president has been briefed
on that when was the last time that he
spoke to the lead negotiators
including republican tim scott we're in
regular touch with the negotiators i
don't have a
timeline or a specific last call with
the president but
senior members of his team are certainly
in close touch we'll let them speak to
where they are
in the process and where they are in
moving the process forward the president
remains
eager to sign the police reform bill
into law
uh go ahead let me go to april and then
i'll come back that's okay go ahead on
police reform
um there is a stumbling block it's
qualified immunity
we're hearing that mainstream policing
organizations
are upset about the financial piece that
it could possibly
bankrupt police officers and police
departments
what does the administration feel about
that for police to be held accountable
and there to be transparency on this and
these police agencies are saying no
because of the financial component of it
what do you say
i would say april that there's an
ongoing discussion and negotiation
between democrats and republicans uh
we're not going to weigh in on that more
specifically from here the president
believes
that it's important that police reform
is long overdue there are difficult
components of this discussion
a lot of those are happening in private
which is the place where they should
continue to move forward
the president be okay with police reform
the george floyd
justice and policing act to be passed
without qualified immunity or component
we're not going to get ahead of the
negotiators who are representing
the interests having challenging
discussions no doubt about how to move
this forward we'll take a look at it
when they have the framework and they're
ready to talk about it publicly
they're also concerned now that senator
chuck scott has the support
of senator lindsey graham on this
policing issue
is there concern he has his support
again april once they are ready to talk
once the negotiators are ready to talk
about the specifics of the framework and
where they are
i'm sure we can speak to that from here
we're not at that point quite yet go
ahead back to the framework to come out
tim scott was supposed to have it today
we'll leave it to the negotiators to
convey when they're ready to talk about
it publicly go ahead
blast you back to afghanistan just real
quick following up on the comments by
general miller
was anything he said to reporters in the
last
day or so new to this white house or had
he conveyed those concerns to the
president
i'm not going to get into private
conversations i will say there have been
intelligence assessments that have been
out there
uh that we have not walked away from uh
certainly we leave that to our
intelligence community to speak to and
that's an important part of
what is put out from the federal
government what i've conveyed to you and
what i'd reiterate
is that uh the president made a decision
because he felt that
uh it was long past time to bring our
troops home
and that there is not a military
solution to the war in afghanistan
we need to continue to support a
political process a political solution
something that our uh our diplomats are
continuing to do
and of course our department of defense
is continuing to work on the timeline of
bringing our troops home
by september at the same time we are
going to continue to be partners to the
leaders in afghanistan and providing
resources and assistance uh wherever we
can
i'm not going to get into any more
details of private conversations go
ahead
and then this is the end of june which
was supposed to be the month of action
on voting rights and it ends with an
interesting
situation in new york city uh as they
try to now retabulate votes
and they won't give us the final result
for at least a few more days
does this white house is the
administration more broadly of any
concern
what's going on in new york given the
fact the president had said earlier this
month in a statement that the work ahead
of us is to make voting accessible to
all american voters and to make sure
every vote is counted through a free
fair and transparent process that
continues to be his hope and his
commitment and his desire
uh but i don't have any assessment from
the white house on the new york
vote counting uh reporting i'll call it
go ahead
does the president want house speaker
pelosi to put a republican on the
january 6 commission
the president uh believes that speaker
pelosi
is acting in an appropriate manner as a
follow-up to
her effort to get a bipartisan
commission passed something that was
blocked as we know uh in the senate by
republicans
and in terms of what the compilation is
and what it looks like he certainly
trusts her uh
her view on this does he think a
republican could act in good faith on
this commission
the president believes certainly
republicans can act in good faith he's
worked with them on a range of
objectives
but he is going to of course rely on the
decision of uh speaker pelosi and how
she wants to see this commission put
forward moving forward and on the bill
cosby
conviction being overturned i know you
said to peter but
it's not because he's innocent it's
because of a decision that a former
prosecutor made so what message do you
think that that sends to women
you know in the metoo era who come
forward with sexual assault allegations
and to see something like this happen
what is your response to that
well i i would say caitlyn that i just
want to be careful about not speaking to
a specific decision by
uh by a court but i can say broadly
speaking as i tried to do earlier
that uh obviously the president is
somebody who has fought for advocated
for
elevating the voices and stories of
women who are survivors of
sexual assault sexual abuse and
certainly uh
knows that's a difficult journey uh for
many of them and he believes that these
women are courageous
they're uh they're brave uh and he wants
it to be an environment wants us to live
in a country
where they where women will feel
comfortable moving forward and
um and telling their story um but again
if there's a specific comment we have as
it relates to this ruling today
i will provide that to all of you after
the briefing go ahead david
uh two follow-ups on things that you
mentioned before
earlier you said that uh we're two weeks
out from the putin
uh summit and you'll remember my timer
okay
yeah that's right and uh you'll remember
that
at that time there was discussion of
setting up some conversations
pretty quickly on cyber and some other
arenas can you tell us whether any of
those have happened when
any of those are planned
so that you don't lose momentum from
this sure i know that the president was
eager
to get those going as soon as we could
many of those will be happening of
course
all of them will be happening below the
presidential level
let me talk with our national security
team and see if there's an update on
what's
underway already and what's ongoing okay
you mentioned the intelligence reports
that were out pretty widely
one of them suggests one u.s report
suggests that
within six months or so kabul could
easily be overrun just given the
progress that the taliban
have made were there any commitments
made to
um president ghani when he was here or
any contingency plans
discussed about what the united states
would do if it did look
like the capital could be overrun i
would say david that
the president reiterated what his
announced position has been
that we are planning to withdraw our
troops from afghanistan
on a september timeline but also
reiterated our commitment to working as
a partner
and to supporting afghanistan uh with
security assistance
humanitarian assistance and others uh we
didn't get ahead of
uh that with uh with uh hypotheticals
you did not get into the specifics of
what i don't have anything more to read
out from the reading
from the meeting let me finish but the
president's commitment
to removing bringing our troops home
from afghanistan has not changed he
reiterated that same commitment in his
meetings on friday
go ahead thanks jen uh tomorrow's
expected to be the last day of the
current term
this supreme court uh historically we've
seen justices who plan
to announce their retirement do so uh at
this time
is this white house making what if any
preparations are you all making
for the possibility that justice briar
will announce your time
we leave that decision to justice breyer
to make are you guys watching this at
all is this something the president
has thought about as we get toward the
end of this term
as you know the president said on his
campaign that he and he committed to
nominate if there was an opening and we
do not know if there's an opening and it
is up to the justices to decide whether
there will be an opening
to nominate an african-american woman to
the supreme court
something that would be history-making
and if there's an opportunity he remains
by that commitment but
we will leave it to any justice to
determine the timeline of their
retirement
follow-up question in florida does the
president plan to speak with governor
desantis when he's on the ground floor
sure it's a good question
i will we will have more details i
expect later today on
the specifics of his visit tomorrow
where he'll be going
who he'll be meeting with uh but i don't
have any specific
meetings with uh elected officials to
read out in touch has
governor desantis and the president have
they talked about the situation and
served sides
as you know they they had a conversation
last late last week also
the president spoke sent his fema
administrator down on sunday he
the president spoke with his fema
administrator to get an update on that
uh at the conclusion of his visit i
don't have any additional calls to read
out for you
go ahead let me ask you
how are those protests being received
here is the president
proud of those activists is he ashamed
by them
what's the view here in the west i would
say first that
we respect the right of anyone to
peacefully protest
that's an american right a fundamental
right i will say that the president
believes that
what's in the infrastructure package is
an important down payment
on addressing what he sees as a crisis
in our climate
a crisis that is a priority one of the
top priorities of his presidency
and i've outlined a few of these items
before but again it's incumbent upon us
to continue to talk about it to make
sure everybody who cares as passionately
as he does
and we do about the climate crisis
understands that
in this package it has the largest
investments in the nation's clean water
infrastructure as
as the administrator noted eliminating
and replacing 100 of lead water pipes
the largest investment in addressing
legacy pollution that harms the public
health of communities and neighborhoods
and billions to reclaim abandoned mines
and cap wells the largest investment in
public transit something that will help
reduce greenhouse gas emissions
in the country it will modernize the
electrical grid with a new grid
development authority and largest
investment state in america's electrical
grid and of course it invests in
electric vehicles i'd also note and you
may have seen a memo we put out
yesterday if not i know we've put out a
lot of paper in the last few days so if
you haven't
i will highlight a few things in there
we also there's components the president
will continue to fight for in the
reconciliation process
to continue this effort including
providing tax cuts for businesses and
consumers who invest in clean energy
technologies
sending a market signal that brings
additional private investment off the
sidelines and into modernizing our
electric grid
through energy efficiency and clean and
electricity standard and mobilizing the
next generation of conservation and
resilience workers
and i say all that because those are all
key components and priorities
that a lot of climate activists talk
about and it's important that
they understand we're fighting by by
their side and with them and we want to
address the climate crisis
yes go ahead more than a million people
in this country according to reports
um are living under a conservatorship or
guardianship
the most famous case has come to light
in the last few weeks it's britney
spears
members of congress on both sides of the
aisle say that maybe there's got to be
some kind of federal law
that governs these relationships is the
white house
does the white house have a view on this
uh in any way
uh i have been watching this case
closely as a point of privilege
um but i will have to talk to our
counsel's office on that because you're
asking me a good
legal question but i don't want to speak
out of turn here
the president has been a bit busy but as
a as a person with young children i
don't have
many places to go go ahead when i'm not
with all of you
absolutely
is there anything the administration
wishes it had done earlier in the
vaccination campaign
that maybe would have led to more
americans being vaccinated or
to have helped you reach the president's
goal of 70 of adults with at least one
shot by this weekend
and what do you attribute the short haul
to well
first i would note that we are on track
to have 70
of people in this country vaccinated 70
i should say of adults 27 and older
vaccinated within a couple of weeks
that's a significant achievement a
significant step forward
we've reduced uh the the uh percentage
of people who are getting kovid who are
dying of covet by 90
that's a huge significant achievement we
are actually much farther
than i think most people would have
predicted we would be less than six
months into
an administration i will note that where
we see challenge and we've seen this as
we've gone along
uh where we see challenge is in among
young people who are under the age of 27
and that is an area where we have we're
going to continue to redouble our
efforts to ensure
that they understand the risks and the
delta variant and
the risks of the delta variant that is
not discriminating by age
uh we that we also make sure people
understand how accessible the vaccine is
and that we make sure they know we're
going to still fight to get them
vaccinated
that's where we're going to redouble our
efforts so no i don't look back i don't
think we look back and
would change i think we are quite proud
of where we are now
and we uh though are going to keep at it
and there's still work ahead
a couple of questions related to covet
and travel
sure national travel in particular um
you mentioned yesterday
in the gaggle that there are these
working groups working on resuming
travel
i'm wondering what the holdups are um
what they're trying to work through
and um also whether the white house
believes that these current restrictions
are keeping americans safe
sure well we wouldn't be putting them in
place if we wouldn't have them in place
if we didn't think they were keeping
americans safe
but i will say the working groups which
are already underway
and are led by the white house coveted
response team and the national security
council
with participation from officials from
across the government
uh they are leading a process that is
led by directed by i should say public
health
there are significant logistical
considerations in safety and effectively
reopening travel they are all taken into
account but they are
continuing to assess we understand
people want to travel we want to travel
too
um we know people want to come here and
people want to travel other places we
understand that but we put these working
groups in place so that we could
work closely and in partnership with
these countries on addressing
the public health challenges vaccinated
europeans to visit the united states
again we're in touch with european where
we have these working groups with
canadians with europeans with others to
determine
the timeline and pace when we can reopen
and do it safely we're not sure about
that though
um a couple months ago andy slavitt i
think it was in one of the coveted
briefings
said that there would not be any sort of
government copic passport however the us
government would provide
guidelines to industry about what
vaccine verification
would look like or best practices um
where are those guidelines
they were always meant to be basically
an faq on the website
um i i don't know that they were meant
to be anything more formal than that
i can certainly check and see what's on
our website or what information i should
say we're
providing to businesses who inquire
because i know
i've spoken to industry groups who are
somewhat concerned that there isn't
much clarity about vaccine verification
of the travel industry for instance
one other question on this um do you
expect that there will ever be a
scenario where the u.s requires
vaccination for travelers coming to the
us
for instance from europe uh or india
from the federal government or from the
airlines or from the federal government
i assume you don't control the airlines
we don't um
i would say that is not our intention uh
go ahead anita
um i just wanted to uh go back to the
infrastructure as well
um so my colleagues had some reporting
earlier today perhaps
perhaps people some people saw about
what
is going to be left out of the
compromise so obviously there are things
that
didn't make it in there um that the
white house is not pushing for them to
be into the in the reconciliation bill
so i guess i'm trying to figure out
is the president still supportive of
those pieces will he push them
if not in reconciliation we push them in
some other
way or are those should people consider
those items
not going anywhere dead um it's perhaps
some democrats on the hill might try to
put them in the bill
anyway the reconciliation bill so i'm
just trying to understand what
what the future is for those projects
sure well first
as the president said last week and you
all know from covering bill making
um there is a lot of work ahead uh for
committee chairs
uh and ranking members uh and they're
gonna be they're already hard at work
with our staff
in many cases but at writing legislation
figuring out what's
next and where this goes from here uh
they're going to be disagreements
that need to be robbed even among
democrats as that
process proceeds what the president will
continue to advocate for
aggressively in the reconciliation
package are key priorities that were
left out of the bipartisan package
including
rebates for electric vehicles i think
some of the reporting suggested we
weren't doing more for electric
vehicles that's incorrect rebates for
electric vehicles clean energy tax
credits
and the components of his american
families plan including an extension of
the child tax credit
universal pre-k ensuring community
college is a real option
those are all components of what the
president will aggressively and
ambitiously advocate for
now we know that there's going to be uh
views
from a range of members some who are
writing the legislation
some who may not feel comfortable with
the size or components of packages
that's what's going to happen over the
next couple of weeks and we'll of course
be closely engaged in that we're not
going to take things off the table or on
the table at this point in time okay i
just want to make sure i understand
because you're saying something is
not correct and i want to make sure i
understood so the items that didn't make
it into the compromise
still could be pushed by the white house
in the reconciliation bill
well i think what i just conveyed is
components of the american jobs plan
including say rebates for electric
vehicles clean energy
clean energy tax credit that were not in
the bipartisan deal
the president would still advocate for
that's something he talked about a
little bit last week
two days ago when we had the last
briefing um in this briefing room
um i asked about the july 4th uh event
and you said you would get some
information and i answered it yesterday
um i didn't see what all the details i'm
happy to repeat it for you
i didn't see that you uh talked about
the
covent precautions so yeah so
guidance was sent out to individuals who
are attending that conveyed that they
should
get tested one to three days before
coming to the white house if they've
been vaccinated
obviously according to public health
guidance they don't need to wear a mask
if they have not been vaccinated uh they
should wear a mask and that's the
guidance that's been provided
so is it still it was 1 000 invitations
or is 1000 people
expected i believe it was 1 000
invitations i think most people are
hopefully accepting their invitation to
the white house but
i don't know that we have a final uh
number for attendees quite yet
we can see if there is with plus ones
okay let me let me just do one more
because you've been so eagerly awaiting
raising your hand go ahead
right there oh you're not eager anymore
go ahead you're ready we're ready this
is the moment
what's your question
yes july 4th celebrations the white
house has been
uh promoting the indian which we can get
together for barbecues
local officials should be having events
things like this has the variant change
any of the white house's encouragement
or plan
should people be more cautious than it
would have been otherwise well first let
me
repeat something that a number of our
public health officials have been
conveying on a number of your networks
throughout the day one we've had them
out there because
we know there's been a lot of questions
about this and confusion and we want to
be as clear as possible
uh we know uh that our vaccines that
have been approved in the united states
are effective in protecting americans
from the delta variant it's important
for people and to understand that so
if you have been vaccinated the message
we're conveying is you're safe
these events these uh vaccines are
effective um and that is something we
want to be very clear with the public
about
uh certainly it's up to individuals if
you are not yet vaccinated
you are not safe and protected that's
why you should go get vaccinated
it's not more complicated than that in
some regards but it's important to note
that
the vaccines that have been approved
here our public health officials have
been out there conveying that they're
safe and effective
we certainly feel comfortable and
confident in moving forward with our
event here at the white house
and in individuals having barbecues in
their backyards
uh this weekend uh to celebrate uh the
fourth of july and america's birthday
thanks so much everyone have a great day
you